[Applaudissements]
alors on tape un petit château avec manu
j'espère que ça va te faire plaisir il
est où il est là hop sentiment en tout
cas c'était cadeau c'était cadeau sait
rien et qu'on s'éclate on a perdu c'est
gratuit c'est grave pour notre actu on
n'a pas facturé s'est abattue ce [ __ ]
je me sens comme un salon gitans de la
au gîte en gîte au salon la caravane
alors attendez est ce que on va jouer
donc avec lorànt deutsch à l'aide par
ces quelques bas qui a retrouvé ses
chiens et diane crois pas possible alors
on va découvrir aujourd'hui et des
animateurs des animatrices télé comme ça
tout le monde peut jouer bas mais c'est
surtout laurent et pète qui joue bien
évidemment s'ils ont besoin d'un coup de
main tout le monde peut les aider
attention première musique
on est parti
[Musique]
tous les dimanches il arrive à 11 heures
sur m6
it s des bagnoles et crois moi c'est pas
les 106 112 en fuyant c'est le même
modèle que belmondo mais de ma femme
l'adorent et quand elle monte dans la
twingo je lui dis en voiture simone
en voiture simone c'est moi qui conduis
et c'est toi qui klaxonnent en voiture
cirad en voiture si mal c'est moi qui
conduis et c'est toi qui claque ça
[Musique]
du coup
magnum et bravo pour la cgt faire vite
viens de me déplacer là il si cela alors
on est deuxièmes musique chez vous chez
vous jouez également on cherche une
animatrice exactement attention celle là
elle est gratinée sais pas musique c'est
une jolie blonde convoi de vie 10 sur d8
même si elle fait pas top chef
j'suis récurent est bien la marmite elle
est à la tête du grand huit et des très
chouette
moi ça me donne envie de porter le
javelot dont la moquette avant sur tf1
quand est présenté sept à huit
elle faisait déjà strictes et
l'unijambiste c'est ce qu'ils ont pas
comprise mais en mettre une couche je
suis pas chasseur mais j'y vais très
bien une carte jeune et je vivais très
bien une cartouche à l'est pas encore
mais très bien une carte ou challenge il
mettrait bien une cartouche
je ne suis pas chasseur mais j'y
mettrais bien eu qu'à deux sont à fou
furieux chiant mais c'est à dire est
qu'un spectacle et à 5000 personnes qui
regardent souvent on est en galère à
montargis la femme et la jeune berger
dame
merci les chéris merci beaucoup aux gars
vous êtes des amours je dis ça je dis
rien ferrari
[Applaudissements]